[موسيقى]
من ابرز الشخصيات السينما الايرانيه
ترنا علي دوسي اعلنت عده مرات دعمها
للمظاهرات التي تشهدها بلادها كما نراها
في هذه الصوره حامله شعاره امراه حياه
حريه
الممثله الايرانيه الشهيره والناشطه في
مجال حقوق المراه اعتقلت من قبل السلطات
الايرانيه لانها لم تقدم وثائقه تدعم بعض
مزاعمها كما يقول القضاء الذي اشار الى ان
توقيفها يعود الى نشرها معلومات ومضامين
كاذبه والتحديد على الفوضى
الممثله الفارغه 38 عاما كانت تردد في
الثامن كانون الاول ديسمبر السلطات
لاعدامها محسن شكري وقبل ذلك وعدت بالبقاء
في بلدها والتوقف عن العمل لمساندتها
عائلات القتلى والمعتقلين خلال المظاهرات
وقالت انها مستعده لدفع الثمن مقابل
الدفاع عن حقوقها
السلطات الايرانيه اعتقلت عده شخصيات
سينمائيه حتى قبل موجه الاحتجاج الحاليه
التي دخلت شهرها الرابع كما اعتقلت الاف
الايرانيين وحوالي 40 اجنبيه منذ منتصف
ايرور سبتمبر بحسب منظمات حقوقيه
ووجهت التهم الى اكثر من شخص على صله
بالمظاهرات وتم اعدام شخصين في الثالثه
والعشرين من العمر على خلفيه هذه
الاحتجاجات